"Essentialism"
In a very confusing world...
...where my options are now practically infinite,...
...and everyone is battling for my time and attention,...
...I needed an operating system with which to live life.
Many times while I was growing up I felt like I was drowning,...
...never able to keep up while everything flew right by.
This book feels like the guide on how to handle it all.
Greg McKeown defines essentialism...
...as "The disciplined pursuit of less, but better".
When I began listening to this book I had the strange feeling...
...that someone was describing the path that I'm already on.
Like flashing a light down a dark tunnel that you're crawling through.
I could immediately see where I was headed.
Just felt real, it felt like a relief.
It felt like clarity on how to act and what to do.
One review of this piece summed things up delightfully: Less is more.
It's also less.
That's the point.
I can't think of a single person...
...that wouldn't benefit immensely from this piece, this way of life.